>> It was just last year that
we reached 100,000 living alumni
of the university in
more than 100 countries.
With this commencement ceremony,
with you graduating today,
we begin CMU's march toward
200,000 living alumni.
When I called Earl Lewis
to be our commencement speaker
this year several months ago he
asked me what should
he talk about.
I said he can talk
about whatever he
chooses to talk about.
We never compared notes.
I had no idea until he started
to speak what he was going
to talk about, and he had no
idea what I'm going to say now.
It's all good.
It turns out that we're
approaching the same theme
from very different angles.
Unbeknownst to each other we
are focusing on a similar theme.
Early this year a group of CMU
faculty members and I travelled
to Switzerland to attend the
World Economic Forum in Davos.
For this meeting which attracts
world leaders, technologists,
industry leaders, policy makers,
writers, film makers, performers
and the global media the World
Economic Forum chose the theme
"The Fourth Industrial
Revolution."
The first industrial
revolution which started
in the late 18th century
created mechanization.
Specifically, according
to one perspective
from the World Economic
Forum, it was the year 1784.
And the catalyst for this
revolution was steam,
water and mechanical
production equipment.
A major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence
of industrialized cities
where some form of human
or animal labor could be
replaced by mechanical labor.
Each revolution created more
advanced forms of manufacturing,
and altered the global
economy in unprecedented
and irreversible ways.
The second industrial
revolution, which started
in the late 19th century,
created mass production.
The catalyst for
this revolution,
considered to have began
in 1870, were the division
of labor, electricity
and mass production.
A major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence
of industrialized regions
and economies of scale.
The third industrial
revolution, which started
in the late 20th century,
created unprecedented
automation.
The catalyst for
this revolution,
considered to have began in
1969, were microelectronics,
information and communication
technologies, the internet,
robotics and automation.
A major outcome of this
revolution was the emergence
of global production networks
and the input costs were
significantly altered.
The fourth industrial
revolution, which many leaders
who are gathered at the World
Economic Forum focused on,
is believed to be occurring
now in the early part
of the 21st century,
although no one is quite sure
when exactly it began.
In my view what makes the fourth
industrial revolution unlike the
previous three stems from
at least a few key factors.
The speed of change.
The role of the individual
citizen of the world whether he
or she is educated or
uneducated, is rich or poor,
lives in a developed country
or a developing country,
he or she can engage in
a two-way communication
at the cutting edge
of the fourth industrial
revolution at lightning speed.
Individual empowerment scale
in which the individual
can do enormous good
and equally enormous
harm, the scope of change,
the impact of that scope of
change on the global system,
intended versus unintended
consequences,
known unknowns, and
unknown unknowns.
You are graduating at a
particularly exciting time
where the convergence
of technologies
and human interactions
with those technologies is
creating new possibilities
and new challenges, new
solutions to problems,
and new threats that
create major new problems
in many domains of
day-to-day life.
On the one hand, the convergence
of the digital, physical
and biological worlds is
generating unprecedented
questions and concerns
about how governments
and individuals will address
such issues as employment,
income levels, equality,
ethics, security, policy,
confidentiality, social
justice, taxation, diplomacy
and global attractions.
At the same time, the
intersections of the real
and virtual worlds, and the
tug of war between natural
and artificial intelligence are
creating interesting questions
about the ways in which the
21st century will unfold during
your lifetime.
In your careers, say 50 years
from now, Earl Lewis talked
about the next 25 years, whether
we emerge as better human beings
or not will critically depend
on how you shape the fourth
industrial revolution,
how you use or abuse the
tools at your disposal,
intentionally or
unintentionally.
Nobody is better prepared
to shape the world
than today's graduates of
Carnegie Mellon University.
CMU faculty, students and
staff played a pivotal role
in their pioneering work that
enabled many of the technologies
that are critical to the
fourth industrial revolution--
computers and computing,
robotics, mobile communications,
big data, deep learning,
science of learning,
artificial intelligence,
human machine interactions,
tools for cybersecurity
and the internet of things.
CMU has purposefully emphasized
to you during the course
of your education
here the importance
of connecting the sciences--
engineering, business
and technologies--
with human creativity
in the arts, humanities,
social behavioral and
decision sciences, and policy.
CMU's own Dr. Herbert Simon,
Nobel Prize-winning pioneering
professor, said in 1971,
"A wealth of information
creates a poverty of attention."
To paraphrase it
differently a wealth
of information can create
sometimes enormous confusion
between what Earl Lewis called
garbage and the real stuff.
Nobody is better prepared
than you to use a wealth
of information deliberately
using careful thought,
reflection and evidence to
address major societal problems.
Our five honorary degree
candidates are role models
and an important connection
between technologies
and the human condition
that will unfold
in the coming years and decades.
Holly Hunter and Sonia Manzano
used their beginnings at CMU
to excel in the arts and
the entertainment world.
And Sonia skillfully combined
entertainment and education
to inspire young minds.
Bob Langer is a pioneering
engineer whose work
at the intersections of
engineering, science,
and medicine shaped
new technologies.
Our own alumnus, Jim Schwartz,
excelled in creating new
business opportunities,
economic value, and societal
impact on a global scale
for those kinds of rapidly
emerging technologies.
Earl Lewis, with a keen eye
and knowledge of history,
used the past to shape
the present and the future
by applying his intellect and
energy to expand diversity
and academia, to
connect the digital world
with the humanities and
through his leadership roles
in academia and non-profits.
As many have said, and
as I have said before,
that some of the greatest
technological achievements
of the 20th century have played
a major role in creating some
of the toughest grand
challenges of the 21st century.
As CMU graduates and global
citizens you have exceptional
talent and unique
cross-disciplinary perspectives
that will enable you to phase
and address these tough problems
without creating new challenges
for the next revolution.
My congratulations to you,
to your families and friends.
And my enormous gratitude
to you for sharing your time
with us during the
past few years.
Congratulations.
[ Clapping ]